and this is our get healthy week here on
good deal las vegas continues this
morning and today
we're focusing on ways for you to stay
fit with the whole family
bianca holman live this morning from the
ymca near meadows mall with ways to keep
you and your kids moving bianca good
morning to you
so the ymca is a place for the entire
family
parents kids grandparents even the
babies they can come and enjoy something
here we've got the pool
they've got the fitness floor where kids
can participate in even the outside turf
and guess where we're at now
the rock climbing wall i'm joined by
autumn hammer so tell us more about
this new space that we're in so our rock
wall is really unique it's at our
heinrich location and there's three
different levels of
climbing on this rock wall each of them
are named for a different mountain to
make cuffing's kind of fun
and it's open monday through thursday
from five to seven and we take
reservations for this
yeah that's so cool but also i know you
all have again the physical activities
for kids for families for adults
they can do the classes together but
what about events you all
have events for families we do have a
lot of events for families so on the
third saturday of the month we have our
family fun day so
in july it is christmas in july and then
in august we have our end of summer
luau kind of celebrating the end of
summer and we also have a take a hike
series so on the fourth saturday
of the month uh why staff will meet at a
family-friendly hike for all different
age
and fitness levels they take a hike and
have fun as a family and get some
exercise in
good good good and i know again you
would tell me you got your own family
got kids
uh why is it so great to uh you know do
events with your family
work out with your family do activities
swim play soccer do rock climbing with
your family
it's really great it's a really nice
environment for
families to be together and to be
physically fit and active together and
that's really important
and then they meet other kids other
families and they just have a great time
together yeah it's so good you know
we're always looking for things to do
with the families with the kids
something that's safe and all in one
space from being physically fit and
building those new habits to events that
you can do
i mean this place has it all so again
keeping our families healthy from
the diapers all the way up until when
you got a cane you're walking around we
want to make sure that you're healthy
and fit
so all great information bianca holman 8
news now
that's pretty cool bianca thank you very
much you should point out by the way
online facebook social media a lot of us
here at 8 news now are doing sort of
fitness discussions talking about what
how we all stay fit i talked about
hockey yesterday online so if you want
to check that out you can do that as
well good stuff 6 38 now